can you give us an idea of what a pitch
meeting is like like in what setting
does it typically take place how long is
it typically lasts well pitch meeting
vary from place to place depending on
what is the focus of the pitch meeting
you can have writer going to a network
to pitch a TV pilot and that could be
anywhere from 10 minutes to 30 minutes
in the actual pitch though I always tell
people to think about the elevator pitch
you know versus the page pitch versus
the three-page pitch and really
understanding story in all of those
parameters so that the situation merits
the outcome like I I've known writers
certainly who've gone and you can have a
writer go into a feature meeting and
they're going to pitch a feature and
that pitch may be longer and so I think
when I look at the pitch meeting and the
pitch process I think the biggest thing
the writer has to be aware of is number
one they have to be prepared and by
prepared I mean not only know their
pitch backward and forward know who
they're meeting with know what they've
done know how their story fits in to
what their business model is know their
background and really when I look at the
pitch meeting I personally look at the
first ten minutes as like being the most
important and utilizing the beginning of
the pitch meeting to create warmth so
that the pitch can really be hurt and
and to create common ground - if there's
something that you love that the person
has produced or something that you love
that you're actually they are mating on
share it like I always tell writers you
never
you can never stroke egos too much
people always want to hear what they're
doing right and what is working and why
it's working so I I always think that
first warm-up time that people don't
really think about is so crucial in the
outcome because number one it then makes
the writer more comfortable it makes who
they're pitching to more comfortable
because they feel connection and it
makes the writer more comfortable
because they feel connection so then
it's moving forward from that and it's
having clarity on what their story is
and I think like I have writer's pitch
to me all the time I mean when I was a
current executive every time we had a
new episode on the show as a current
executive my job was working with the
executive producers on staffing the show
with writers and directors as well as
working with them on from story concept
to outline to script to screen so during
that process that's all we were doing
was hearing pitches hearing story
pitches what works what doesn't work why
it doesn't work what could be stronger
and then seeing notes from those pitches
made and I think a part of my process
with writers is I always want them to
when I start a consult
that is a script console isn't even a
pitch consult but I'll start a script
console and I'll say pitch me your story
and I always get people oh I wasn't
prepared for that like I'm not I said
this is what I want you to know you are
always going to be pitching your story
so you have to be comfortable with it I
am about is safe the safest person who
could be hearing it so don't I'm not
judging your pitch I want to hear your
story I wonder if I want to understand
how you see your story like a large part
of what I'm looking for in a script
console is what's in the mind and the
heart
but isn't hitting the page and how
through the process of the console do we
help to you
UniFi so the heart and the mind is
hitting the page and so that we're
feeling the story that they intended to
tell do you ever see writers who are so
socially awkward because they can't
believe they've made it to see this
person that normally under normal
circumstances they'd be hey I love the
show I'm you know but because this is
their big moment they the nerves get in
the way oh yeah and all of that goes out
the window and they're more like a sort
of a was it automatron or so you know
just they're more robotic yes and you
know the answer to that like the answer
to nerves period is preparation I think
the biggest reason people are nervous is
because they're not prepared and I I
think when we what what I tell writers
to recognize is most of the time they're
going into a pitch meeting the person
that they're pitching wants it to work
as much as they want it to work
no one wants wasted time everyone wants
it to work so they are starting the
process with someone on their side and
and I think as soon as they hear that
that it helps to alleviate some of the
stress and I said you also have to
remember that the person you're pitching
to started at the bottom - they started
with the dream the only difference
between you and them is they're in the
process of achieving the dream and
you're also being given the opportunity
to start that process so there's there
really isn't this big divide it is two
people who have the mutual desire to see
it work okay so then let's talk about
the self-deprecating pitcher versus the
used-car salesman it's all great and I'm
a fantastic pitch I think like
self-deprecation
can work if you have the charisma and
charm to pull it off
I think self-deprecation can get in your
way if you truly believe what you're
saying
with regards to the negativity involved
so I think it's Unversed is the ego I
think that you know I've heard writers I
think the biggest thing not to say is do
not tell them how good your pitches and
I have seen writers do that oh this is
going to be like the best thing you've
ever heard or this is one of the
strongest and there's a difference
between confidence and arrogance and
when you have the arrogance yet the
content doesn't meet the level then it
fails
you